Blake libel and his girlfriend Jana
cassian lived together in a Hollywood
condo until police found casseon
murdered libel says her death was linked
to gambling debts but investigators
turned to his book to search for clues
48 hours correspondent maureen maher
takes us inside this week's 48 hours
Blake libel was born into an incredibly
wealthy Canadian real estate family but
in his early 20s he moved to Hollywood
to make it big and it was libels idea to
write this graphic novel syndrome about
a vicious murderer he married a model
and had two children with her he had a
girlfriend on the side and then fell in
love with yet a third woman Yannick
Ossian was an immigrant from the Ukraine
and had a baby with Blake her biggest
dream was to you know have children to
raise a family here in the United States
her mother Olga Jana was happy you know
but she she was very happy and he too
despite that happy picture there was a
time when Blake had worried he might
lose everything because of his brother
Cody is a big man about town you know
loves fast cars
he's the flashy brother the classy one
yeah Cody was a big gambler says Scott
Johnson a writer for The Hollywood
Reporter and a 48 hours consultant
Johnson says Cody played in a
high-stakes poker circuit called Molly's
game which was recently depicted in a
Hollywood movie they were going all-in
all the time Blake's feared justified or
not was that the celebrity poker game
had some dangerous characters Russian
mobsters who might seek revenge on his
own family because he believed Cody owed
them a lot of money and he was
expressing these fears in text messages
to a very close friend in May 2016
Yanis seemingly charmed life came to a
horrible end police swarmed this
building after a mother's intuition told
her something was not right with her
daughter this case reads like a movie
correct it's just more like a horror
movie the injuries he suffered were
horrific Blake himself pointed
detectives in the right direction
telling them science is gonna tell you
who did this and the science of the
blood evidence would shock everyone Wow
yes
it's stunning yes it is and marine Maher
joins us here at the table welcome you
know we noted the the reference to
Molly's game and the family actually has
a connection to that as well what role
did that play in the investigation so it
actually plays no role in the
investigation it's on the Outer Rim of
it his brother Cody libel was involved
with the game and because he had owed
money we believe to the game there was a
concern by Blake libel who's the
defendant in this case that somehow the
Russian mafia was after him but in the
end he doesn't even use that as part of
his scenario of what may or may not
happened inside this condo it's a it's
probably one of the more gruesome
stories I have ever covered so much so
you can't even talk about it why was the
lack of blood or blood or lack of blood
so Horton in this case what's important
about that is that they expected to see
a lot more evidence around the condo and
they didn't and because of that they
called in a luminol export I think most
of us have heard of that and the reason
they did it even though they figured out
how she died they had an idea and who
did it it's that they wanted to know her
story and every victim has a story and
even if they can't tell their story they
still have deserve to have their story
told right Maureen Maher thank you you
can watch Maureen's
report on 48 hours tomorrow at 10:00
9:00 central right here on CBS